[Musique]
gk tout ça c'est mon frère
ça c'était moi et ça c'était une super
vieille dame qui nous gardaient qui
était juste en train de visiter au jour
elle était juste prêté à la faire là je
le sens et ça c'était la maison de ma
grand mère il y avait mon parquet de
dallas et ça nous semblait aimante et
ses drôles de les garder les maisons
fantômes parce que ça n'existe plus et
bien c'est ici l'univers de jane birkin
j'écris spasmodique ment toujours
mais j'avais commencé à sérieusement à
12 ans parce que j'étais dans l'internât
alors je pense que et qu'est ce que
c'est
misère à 12 ans j'ai des privés toujours
pour lui et pour 7 5
ça commence toujours je vais enfin et
j'avais écrit ça pour c'était pour
parler à moi si vous avez personnes en
parler avec vous écrivait est forcément
qu'on vous êtes heureux vous n'avez pas
le temps d'écrire vous savez que le
temps quand vous êtes malheureux
des quelque chose
à la sortie de l'école la petite c'est
charlotte et l'a86
combien
100 francs
amman
frank lee
et ça parce qu'il aime les sols
je vous le dis tout bas mais jen elle a
33 ans notre anglaise est né à
nottingham une ville industrielle du
grand nord britannique
nous avons été reçus comme des princes
charlotte nous a même joué du piano
sympathique aussi le tea time
serge gainsbourg était presque là en
tout cas il ne nous a jamais vraiment
quitté des illégaux
quand vous avez 12 ans et que tous les
fils ricardo ou de la porte de la salle
de bain en 12 ans a alors jen toujours
rien parce que vous n'avez pas les seins
qui poussent appelait ça le le peur de
neige pas les mêmes que les autres parce
qu'il avait toujours cette sorte de le
complexe oui de devoirs que tout le
monde pousse au même moment alors si
vous n'étiez pas en avance comme les
autres ou même peut-être normal comme
les autres ça fait que de taki neige est
épouvantable
après on s'en fout appréhender balle tu
les revois ils sont énormes et mais ça
c'est alors que à oui ça ça ne peut pas
vous marquez
ma mère était actrice alors c'est le
premier film c'était son idée
elle avait acheté une caméra qui était
assez rare à l'époque là on a fait une
film de quand je bondis mon flair et
c'est ma mère qui faisait le mettre en
scène
j'ai pris conscience de mon père
sûrement vers vaduz an plus tôt 12 13 et
après m'emmener dans une voyage en
italie juste lui et moi les gens nous a
pris pour des fiancés gt
j'étais très flatté
[Musique]
regarde je donnais un bouquet à la reine
angoissé à 12 ans dont le père yeux plus
solitaire les jeux je sais pas je
voulais faire du bien je pensais que je
partirai dans des pays lointains qui
fait quelque chose d'inutile
[Musique]
moi j'avais des mauvais résultats mais
en dix ans elle essaye tellement il faut
pas trop gueuler alors j'ai essayé
beaucoup j'avais déjà vu des sujets qui
me passionnait à cause d'une maîtresses
que j'aimais beaucoup qui fait que pour
l'histoire parce que j'ai toujours adoré
des anecdotes d'alois l'histoire des
toitures anglaise j'étais pas mal là
dedans mais j'ai pas eu des buttes un
formidable mais c'était toujours pour le
comportement c'était très bien qui fait
que l'école pour moi c'était une
mentalement assez assez torturé parce
que je voulais toujours avoir des bonnes
notes j'avais peur de décevoir mes
parents où les chefs d'école chef de
noche qui beaucoup quoi que ce soit
[Musique]